Hello, and welcome to this new lesson. In this lesson, you will learn more
about how to become a pro at writing classes. We will start out with how you
can discover which classes you should be implementing. Have a look at this
description of a task that should be programmed. In a social network, people
can send messaged to their friends and they can see pictures that their friends
like. How do we know what classes might make sense of this situation? There is
a very simple rule. Look for nouns in the problem description. Many of them can
be good candidates for classes. So we might want to make a class person or
message. What about friend? Well, a friend is just a kind of person so we might
not be using that one. So, it's not that every noun turns into a class, but the
nouns give a good idea where to start. What about methods? Well, methods are
verbs. For example, here, sending would correspond to a method. And in
object-oriented programming, there's this core belief that a method belongs to
a class. There is a single class that is responsible for sending, and so we
would want to make a choice. Is it the person class that has a send method, or
is it the message class that has a send method? Or maybe there's another class
that we haven't yet discovered, maybe a mailbox class. We're not going to get
into the details about this application. Here I just wanted to point out the
noun-verb rules. Nouns are good candidates for classes, verbs are good
candidates for methods. And I wanted to remind you, that each method is the
responsibility of a single class. In this lesson will be implementing a fairly
complex program, and we'll start out by just covering the classes that we need.
The program that we want to develop deals with car sharing. So, we know car
sharing is great, means less waste, less environmental damage, people travel
together when they can. So, we want to write an application that simulates car
sharing so that we can learn how to make it better. Here is a problem
description. So, cars can pick up people whose destination is along the way of
their own. The simulation should read information about cars and passengers and
print out who has been driven where. What I'd like you to do is to read through
this description and tell me what might make some good classes to implement in
a program that does this car-sharing simulation. Let me give you a few choices.
Which of these do you think would work out? Check all that apply.